let's um let's hit uh what you're going
to
be uh releasing do you have the journal
of consciousness studies
and we have that um so
tell us about what like what is um
how do we test that like the hypothesis
because we've been you know yeah we've
been talking about it
so much um living mirrors theory so what
what do we do for
um proper like is there a randomized
control trial like
yeah yeah and or do we have to use
simulation technology to to
like yeah yeah yeah go ahead good
so yeah i would say computational
modeling like simulating
and um would be one step but that's
going to be
i mean you know technology is increasing
exponentially right so maybe it's not
that far away
right now the simulations we can do are
so puny we can't simulate a single cell
like it that it's too complex as a
single cell
but we can do kind of quite simple
simulations with this stuff
um so what would be nice would be to be
able to simulate a single cell
and then so say you have a bacteria and
you could effectively
simulate based on the statistical
physics the patterns in its environment
it's a fight you
you find out its fitness functions and
you model what you think its structure
of its consciousness should be like
you know what dimensions of kind of
photo you know of like light
sensitivities they have
and then you do behavioral experiments
where you would you would basically test
it flashlights make it respond for
nutrients and stuff and just see like
does the theory predict the structure of
consciousness
and that would be the kind of gold
standard way of really
you know it's not a um i guess yeah in
that in that picture you would be able
to just see like do
does it fall out of the theory does it
match up if it doesn't match up the
theory is probably not right
um but the other kind of more gradual
approach which is similar
is that the the actual um
the kind of mathematical basis of the
theory is not some
um kind of fringe you know bit of bit of
science
it's actually the emerging mainstream
picture of how the brain works is
it's been described as kind of a
hierarchical inference it's like this
idea of the bayesian brain it's what's
called the free energy principle
all of this stuff is is about using
exactly the same mathematics as it
applies to the single cell
um to understand how the brain works and
this this was best fleshed out by a guy
called riston
uh his neuroscientist at the same
university as me he's done some
wonderful work here and
and this is to me is you know more and
more people are lining up to
to think of the brain in these terms and
so
the the living mirror theory just fits
perfectly alongside it it just says
here whilst you're doing your
neuroscience studies in the human brain
as well as just saying okay i know a
human brain is conscious
but i don't know what to say about any
other living system this theory gives
you a way of saying well alongside your
experiments you can say
this is a way of thinking about which
systems are conscious why they're
conscious when you know where in the
universe they're conscious
and so what i hope is that people will
gradually just kind of in the same way
with
the theory of evolution people there was
no there was no experiment to test it
really
but the kind of gradual just seeing how
it made sense of everything it just fit
with
all the data everyone gradually was like
oh okay this is the right way of
thinking about it
that's where i'm at personally with
being like okay as someone who's
always been passionate about trying to
understand the mystery of consciousness
you know i've read the different things
on offer and they don't they just don't
sit right
with me if they had sat right with me
you know i would have stuck with those
but i mean this isn't controversial no
one
you know yeah we're not in a situation
where we think consciousness is solved
right like
um there is nothing wherever it's like
yep this is definitely the answer
so that would be my um my hope but the
problem is that it really hinges on
the radical change in humanity in the
kind of consciousness of humanity that
you described like well you know
having more people realize what they
really are
there's there's a sense in which so
we spoke about the idea that there is
this uh evolutionary process there is
kind of becoming and
and we get more and more ability to
create order and control the world
and that's what's kind of got us to
where we are now but we're living so
much in that
side of things we're living so much in
separation and control that we have
these you know
societies that are structured around
progress progress progress you know use
humans as machines to kind of
to generate more material stuff and
and we're not balanced enough into the
kind of the being side of things
when you when you're in the kind of you
know the being side of things
that's when you can look at a plant and
say oh you're me like we're the same
thing
i totally gather you would be conscious
so i think most humans have this kind of
tunnel vision of separation where after
generation
and generation of going on this kind of
progress mode
with all of its kind of feelings of
trauma and being distant from the rest
of the natural world
we feel like that the punchline of
consciousness has to be
that we are special that we are
different that our separation
our felt separation from nature is a
good thing ultimately because we are
it's what gives us our consciousness
it's you know we're these these truly
different things
but i i think we're just that
perspective is one of
this kind of stress traumatized
dissociation and tunnel vision
and if we all come back into just being
we recognize our unity with nature we
we would look at a plant and recognize
it as an extension of the same thing
that created us
and suddenly you're like oh okay i get
it pants can be conscious that totally
makes sense and we see this in people
who engage in spiritual practice or
after psychedelics and they really
kind of see through the kind of the
delusional structures and consciousness
for what consciousness really is
and they're brought into this being mode
more um
yeah and i think if so i think actually
peop widespread if it turns out i'm true
my theory is true or i'm correct i think
the limiting factor will be
that perspective will be people having a
kind of knee-jerk reaction of like no
ways
is that true because i my feeling of
separation is i'm so attached to it
same same thing with darwin and
evolution right it's like don't tell me
i'm the same as an ape like
i don't like to hear that because i have
this real feeling of like
not being at peace and struggling and
being separate um
so yeah it's quite a maybe unlike this
is why consciousness is such a tricky
thing to address i think because it's so
close to home we have
it's not only to do with what we are is
to do with what reality is
and so we have such emotional investment
in in what this answer is and whether it
satisfies us
that i think um unlike other problems
there's yeah that could be a big
boundary to whether or not it's ever
accepted as as correct but also it could
be wrong
two ways uh to hit the ball back there
the first one is uh yeah super
eloquently
described with the tunnel vision of
separation and that
slowly becoming more and more augmented
and awakened
uh and harmonized especially between
um the importance of seeing the the
collective symphony
at the same time as seeing a unique gift
and artistic contribution those two
things together are critical
and then on the first part that you
mentioned let's talk about the
mathematics
here i think this is very interesting
chow tong when we had him on the show in
china
he was so um insightful
and visionary about the fact that we are
literally going to need
new math to understand how life works
and i think that's so profoundly
interesting because like you described
even given such extreme successes with
computational capacities
how do we actually simulate the inner
workings of even a single cell and how
it interacts with its environment
and then how we can basically prove the
idea is that that you can prove there's
like a mathematics
of consciousness of that cell that when
it does
get a like a light source as an
input that it does register that and
that it makes an
output and like that's the idea of
a of a of a of an attempt
at a a deeper living mirror theory of
understanding and how a multi-cell
organism has like a slightly more
complex mathematical computation of its
of
understanding it's of its environment is
that the general
trajectory alongside what mainstream is
yeah
i think where we're currently at the
maths is is is coming along
well actually like so this again this is
mainly the work of cole fristen and
what's called the free energy principle
um and the existing state of it is i
mean it is complicated
maths um and so it's but it's it's not
um
you know it's it's it's not like
inventing a whole new branch of
mathematics i guess
but it's uh fundamentally the the idea
is that
if that in order to exist you need to
minimize the kind of disorder in your
boundary if you don't minimize the
disorder in your boundary you're not
going to exist you're going to dissolve
into it and if you look at that kind of
physically
the mathematics describe that physically
it's the same you can rearrange it and
it basically says that
it's the same as what's called bayesian
inference which is again this i
mentioned the bayesian brain the idea
that
this is just a kind of branch of
mathematics that's to do with how you
build models of the world how you tested
against
um hypotheses how you test your
hypotheses against
data and in my in my theory what i
should actually make clear is that
the math describes the the contents of
consciousness the structure
so in this picture you'd be able to say
okay that primate with its three
different types of photoreceptors or
color sensor photoreceptors
has trichromatic vision it has these
kind of three dimensions of color and
we can map out this kind of structure
the fact of consciousness
is not something that can be you know
that's where you need to zoom out to
this kind of
to the universe really to the picture of
the environment and the organism
and like a reflection it exists in the
interaction between the
the organism and its environment so the
question of to go back to
where you said before about can ever be
proven the idea you would never be able
to prove
this organism has consciousness this
organism doesn't have consciousness
this is just you know one of the
features of consciousness is private
right and i can speculate that you have
it because your physiology is so similar
to mine
it would be really unsurprising it'd be
very surprising if you had a similar
you're a similar organism without
consciousness that would just see it
would seem so
so weird that i'm willing to grant it to
you um
and then with a theory you can start to
think okay i'm willing to grant it to
these other
organisms for these reasons but there
can never be
i can never prove that you're not a
robot you know like or a zombie is the
kind of philosophical term for being
with no without consciousness um and so
the mathematics
would really be making progress in terms
of cashing out
whether we've got a handle on how the
contents are structured but then if
if the theory manages to pull that off
then
it's good to assume that it's it's right
in some fundamental way
okay so living mere theory is a heavily
grounded in the mathematics of the
uh structure of consciousness
well no so i would say the basic insight
is is just the conceptual one we said
before
you can really we could not talk about
thermodynamics at all and we could just
say if you're going to exist
you need to know what's going on around
you and i think for some people they
might think yeah that makes sense
like that's a that makes more sense than
maybe
i don't know saying if your brain
oscillates at 40 hertz then you're
conscious that seems
that doesn't seem to hold any intuition
so so is the explanation
is it is it then fair to say that it's
the mathematics of the living system and
the way that it is coupled with its
environment yeah so it is yeah so
so the mathematics only comes in when it
when you know it was it's a scientific
theory so if you want to test it you
want to
you want to get precise that's where it
comes in but you don't need to worry
about
the actual kind of okay that level of
granularity
to to feel you've got a handle on what
i'm what i'm claiming
yeah yeah correct that's kind of where
we started um
is having the handle on it without the
math but then i see where um where
because i'm so interested in the actual
process of getting
people around the world to go okay what
we're triangulating on and what
5 000 plus years of metaphysical
lineages on consciousness across the
world are
triangulating on is the exact same thing
and um that that's why um i i want
the math to succeed i want the
hypotheses to be
uh proven over time uh and
successfully uh over and over and over
again um yeah and that's why i ask about
the math and and the complicated process
of doing the simulations of
the coupling of the living system with
its
um environment and then kind of like the
the idea is that the math you're we're
in a sense we're watching
the changes of the math
we're watching those changes to
determine in consciousness you mean
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting i mean
it gets a bit
uh i need to be careful because if it's
like you're watching it's like you're
conscious of
these other things so i would say i
would say the maths is the math and the
theory are always just maps for the
territory right so
this is a picture where it's not like
consciousness is just information
processing it's not like the computer
analogy for the brain where
you just assume it's this very thin kind
of uh
description of what's going on it's
really a body it's like you have this
real
like existence that's happening right
now and it's a real process
and when you have a system that believes
things about in
about the world around it this is what
it feels like um
and the theory and and mathematical
descriptions are just
maps they're just saying here's how it
should play out if we've got a really if
we've got a
antelope that's going on this is what it
what it should look like um
so the consciousness itself is embodied
in the world
and this then the theories are just
they're descriptions they're a language
game ultimately
um which is why if you if you forced me
to choose between science and
spirituality i would choose to just
meditate the rest of my life away
instead of uh you know the game of
trying to put it into words and
in other forms of language is not as uh
it's not as real it's it's a story it's
ultimately a story